late Wednesday after initially trailing
a voter initiative appears to have been
a proof to make Denver the first US city
to decriminalize magic mushrooms and
it's thanks to these people at this
election night party Kevin math uses the
campaign manager behind decriminalized
Denver the political activist group that
got the measure on the ballot he also
personally testifies to the power of
psilocybin mushrooms which he says
helped cure his depression I was a cadet
at the US Military Academy and my life
dream was to serve my country as a
career army officer and while I was at
the Academy I was diagnosed with major
depression and then I eventually
received a medical retirement from the
army because of depression and it felt
like that my purpose had basically
crumbled apart and disappeared and then
I met an amazing group of friends here
in Denver who responsibly introduced me
to civil Simon and it was this one
experience that I had just cleared the
fog and so after that experience the
benefits lasted for weeks that really
enabled me to step outside of the box of
depression and start to create a new
life for myself without needing to go
back to using the mushrooms again
campaign political coordinator Cindy so
vine brought her experience lobbying for
increased access to cannabis to the
psilocybin mushroom fight if there is
anything that this country should be
talking about after we do this in Denver
is that as we have set the container to
decriminalize all drugs this is about
harm reduction and we need to start
there before we start talking about
legalizing anymore because we should not
be giving people the ability to make a
profit off of the sale of a legal
product while we're still putting people
in jail for using that product then for
police have averaged an arrest of about
50 people a year for the past three
years for possessing or selling
psilocybin mushrooms and prosecuted
about 11 of those cases last year
according to the Washington Post but so
vine says that while the numbers may be
small the personal impact is huge if you
are the
mother or the son or the brother or the
father of one of those individuals it is
still a priority in fact one of the
folks very much involved in our campaign
is one of those people who was arrested
at thrown in jail and still to this day
has ramifications within his life for
what he can and cannot do because of
psilocybin so vine also says she
believed Denver already had the
psychedelic culture necessary to be the
first to try decriminalization a culture
which is on display in the city's Rhyno
Art District that features buildings and
an entire alley covered with psychedelic
street art the psychedelics are already
here there's already a psychedelic
Renaissance happening we're seeing
different types of providers that are
coming in and now using this innate
pathways Maps up in Boulder who are
doing all these types of research
there's a lot more information available
here in this community and locally
around what's happening and they're
being used they're being used in the
music scene they're being used all over
we are looking at that and recognizing
that we don't think that people should
be going to jail or you know otherwise
is losing their livelihoods for the
result of using this substance Colorado
was one of the first two US states to
legalize recreational cannabis sales
which it did by voter initiative in 2012
putting it on the frontier of American
drug policy then and now this is the
best place in the country to do this
right now
Denver and maybe the state of Colorado
is in in many ways at least with drug
policy embracing more of this
libertarian concept that you know as
long as I'm not causing harm to self or
others we should be we should have the
freedom to use whatever substances we
choose and put into our bodies whatever
we choose Denver's decriminalization
initiative makes the possession or use
of psilocybin the city's lowest law
enforcement priority and prohibits the
city from spending resources to impose
criminal penalties for the personal use
and personal possession of psilocybin
mushrooms by persons 21 years of age and
older and also establishes a panel to
review the effects of the change in law
it does not legalize commercial sales of
mushrooms leaving a potentially large
gray market so vine says her experience
in cannabis legalization which
progressed from medical to recreational
every state that
legalized it convinced her that
decriminalization rather than
medicalization is actually the far more
radical and Liberatore path to take
maybe we want to see doctors being able
to prescribe psilocybin but is that the
only way we want to be able to access it
should we still be going to jail and
having it be a criminal offense outside
of having a physician prescribe it for
you lawfully I think that the core
tenant and the reason why the campaign
became what it was today was because we
don't necessarily think that going
through that process necessarily means
access to all patients groups like the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies or Maps have spent
nearly 33 years funding the study of
psychedelics for treating mental and
emotional problems and that work is only
recently reaching fruition with a study
of the psychedelic MDMA to treat
post-traumatic stress disorder about to
enter the final phase of FDA clinical
trials and the organization is hopeful
it will achieve full approval for use in
clinical settings by 2021 scientists
like Charles Grove at Johns Hopkins have
also studied psilocybin in a clinical
setting and found a measurable decrease
in death anxiety among terminal cancer
patients dosed with the drug sometimes
just a single time our subjects reported
being more engaged in their lives
getting a renewed sense of self and a
renewed sense of meaning and purpose to
the time they had remaining but
advocates say the more radical
decriminalization movement complements
rather than undermines the work of
groups like maps psilocybin mushrooms
have the potential to address the five
psychiatric symptoms that we're facing
as a country and those things are
depression anxiety addiction PTSD and
pain well the research is amazing it it
costs a lot of money and takes a lot of
time and the fact that people are being
criminalized today as we speak is a big
motivation for why we're doing this work
on the horizon activists are working to
put statewide psilocybin
decriminalization on ballots in Oregon
in California in 2020 both so vine and
Matthews believe that what happened in
Denver won't stay in Denver
part of a team from California is here
tonight now they came out to support us
and I know that petitioners in Oregon
the the best of mice I can offer is to
find volunteers who are committed to
this fundraising is key really respect
and honor the research and the
researchers who have dedicated their
entire lives to this work they need to
be a part of the conversation it starts
by forcing the the conversation and and
protecting access whether you're using
this plant for a medical reason or a
spiritual reason or a recreational
reason you should not be going to jail
or losing your children for it
[Music]